there seems to be like this like
frustration with you know in dating for
men lately and I'm just curious like
if you felt it ever like dating women
like yeah it sucks I just think it's a
perspective thing and you don't really
get the other side of you don't have to
experience the other side so when I was
dating then I just truly didn't
understand
how awful I was being until I became a
man and then I was like oh I was making
so many things crazy for no [__] for
example whoa and it was like but it's
also it's also like a confidence thing
too right it's the way women are
positioned in society that causes a lot
of these issues because women we are
taught to attach ourselves to men and
that's where our value comes from now
you can talk a lot [__] oh no that's not
the case but at its core it is the case
it is the case and so so much of you is
reflected in the God and the guy and he
has so much power he has so much power
to determine if you lose all your status
if you guys stop seeing your existence
in a way and so you you feel so I didn't
realize how powerless I was actually
feeling in that position and you were
probably acting out because you felt
powerless right and and yes and and
being smothering and being all these
things because
your definition is so in relation to him
so if you if you leave me I lose
everything so I got to be on your ass so
I don't lose everything yes
and that's why you
[__]
Sam's the new entertainment
okay this makes so much sense because
you've been to the other side you know
what I mean like you're like blade yeah
the gay walk without the bike
Shay called me that really really that's
funny okay okay okay so this is not okay
so the the jealousy the smothering often
comes from this idea that their identity
is wrapped into who the guy is yeah and
maybe women don't even understand no
they don't because it's just a natural
thing right like like this one here you
got something you know oh like when I
had a boyfriend I was going to I was
doing my thing I was going to school and
he was in college but I felt such a need
to like support him and make sure like
his thing was good because it was like
as long as his thing's good then our
thing's good and then thus my thing's
good right but in that you lose your
your own self-identity and your own like
your own fight for your own life and
autonomy right and then it was until I
became uh like a masculine Center
lesbian that's out here dating women
because now everything changes right now
and now there's different things I need
to attract women right like as a woman
to attract a man all I gotta do is show
up I just gotta show up and not be the
ugliest [__] in the room and like
something will come to my way yeah once
you're in a masculine position it's like
you have all these requirements you have
to be able to protect somebody you have
to be able to provide for somebody so by
Nature you're gonna be ambitious because
getting the things is what gets you the
[__] yes it the other way it doesn't
work that way you don't you don't need
women to have [__] to be with them a
[__] could be sleeping on another
bitch's couch you'll still [__] her and
if you love her you'll just bring her
into your home yeah but [__] ain't
out here picking up homeless [__] yeah
it don't go that way yeah yeah so that
changes just you get what I'm saying 100
yeah yeah yeah there's there's almost
like whoa no but but it's like these
reactions over here
if you haven't seen Sam's stand up it's
amazing I've said this to you before
I'll say again she is female Patrice to
me and if you know how much we love
Patrice that's lofty lofty praise but
I've said that to you I think when you
were dating this is one more fem or like
would he come home and just dab him up I
mean I was I didn't really have a sense
of my masculine dang I've always been
some level of this but it was definitely
way more feminine oh definitely way more
feminine now now you were saying before
like in terms of like incentive for
Success you're like dudes are
incentivized to succeed and be ambitious
because that's how you get the girl so
as a girl
like my mom was was very successful you
know what I mean like is that
you more unique that you find a woman
that is incentivized for Success that
has nothing to do without attaining I
think the dude I see so it of course
there's always going to be Nuance yes
right yes there's no nothing is sweeping
nothing yeah but I think it's also right
a little bit of it is class too because
a certain class level you need to as a
woman you're trying to attract a certain
type of man at a certain level right so
it's like oh I need to go get these
things because it allows this type of if
I'm not this then I can't date the guy
who went to Ivy League or something like
that also there might be another a
little bit of nuance where it's like if
you are incredibly passionate about a
thing that passion drives you and then
success comes with the passion yes where
it's not you're not going I just need
status you just love like my mom dance
or whatever but like you just love a
specific thing yes so so have you felt
yes to the passion of it 100 and that's
the main thing right like the main thing
too is like a lot of times it you I
think I I've always found like it's like
when you're when you're in a masculine
you have to identify all this stuff kind
of
earlier because you need it to do [__]
like you gotta you're saying as you're
in your position yeah like you gotta
because you can't
like
you have to learn a new identity almost
yeah and you can't like you can't
I had a yeah because it's like I'm used
to going out and [__] buy me drinks
I'm used to go I could go out with no
money really yeah and still have a night
and then I heard masculine and like
[__] are like what's up and I'm like
damn I'm broke so now my mind is like yo
I can't be a broke [__] I gotta figure
out what I'm gonna do
yo there's no such thing because as a
broke girl I'm gonna get [__] up like
I'm not gonna be able to get [__] now
I'm competing now I'm in the race I'm
watching they're getting more they're
they're getting their women are more
attracted to them so it's like oh okay I
gotta be able to play this game wow all
right guys we're gonna take a break for
a second because you never know what
could happen to you in your life what
you do need is Morgan and Morgan that's
what you need Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest entry Law Firm they
have over 100
this is Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers listen with over 15 billion
dollars recovered for their clients
Morgan Morgan has proven track record of
fighting to get you your full and fair
compensation okay submitting a claim to
Morgan Morgan it's like order and take
out then hiring a lawyer so if you're
ever injured you can check out Morgan
and Morgan their fee is free unless they
win think about that there's no cost
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com flagrant or dial
pound law okay that's pound 529 from
your cell phone that's f o r the
people.com